what I'm about to enact here you are
going to enact but to do it faster and
more efficiently that's what your
laptops are going to help with okay
right so here's what I've got at the
moment is the arrangement I have three
boxes okay and I've got one prize here
let me show you what this is now this
this is paradox by the way remember
we've talked about the fact that there
are paradoxes we call them fallacies
that are that they actually are false
but they seem to be true they seem to
this seem to hold together okay now what
we're going to cost over issue is
something which seems to be false but
actually is true so I'm gonna give you
the reverse kind of situation for this
right now this saw this paradox I'm
going to give you has a name it's called
the Monty Hall problem now raise your
hand if you've heard of multi Hall X
okay thank you hands down okay I knew
that I knew that a lot of you would have
heard of this which is why I didn't want
to include it in this group of five okay
the challenge for you guys that is to
remember why it is true and how'd it how
to explain it because even after people
have been showing their reside it's
still like really I'm not convinced okay
because it seems so false right like I
said it's the reverse of the situation
in the Monty Hall problem Monty Hall is
I am he's a game show host
okay so he kind of like he's got a
instead of three boxes
he has three doors and there's a prize
behind one of the doors and then there's
something you don't want behind the
other two doors so I think it's like a
car behind one door and then like sheep
or goats behind the other door like they
might say McGrath right so I decided not
to punish you I just have some empty
boxes okay and I have a present at the
moment you can see which box the prizes
here you can see which box surprises you
so in order to make this work I can call
this box one box two box three I want to
put the
that's that's not gonna help is it okay
I'm gonna put the lid on in a second
yeah see I actually brought like a same
color one I don't know where it's gone
so yeah all right
I don't put the lids on a second I'm
gonna reshuffle that but I'm going to
ask you all to turn around because
otherwise the whole the whole exercise
on the way okay so you so actually what
I'll do is I'll get you to i'm stand up
now and turn around face the other wall
so I can do this so the prize is in one
of these boxes okay and call this box
one box two box three okay now here's
what we're going to do rather than get a
class consensus type thing I'm going to
get each of you to have your own guess
I'm gonna kitchen right down okay where
you can put on your laptop if you like
okay you get the opportunity to guess
which box you think the prize is in box
one box two box three okay box one box
two box three don't try to predict right
now I'm just gonna do some chickens yes
okay good I'm just making sure that what
I did is right okay
now you should all have selected our box
okay one two or three and just for the
sake go for the sake of illustration I'm
gonna ask for which box is most common
in the class and we'll make that the
class's choice okay so hands up box one
box this is bot one two three hands up
box one hands up so alright this three
okay
so unbox when I've got one two three
four five six five five one but one okay
box to raise your hands okay one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve
which leaves box 3 X 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ok
alright interesting okay so as a class
as a class you have now selected box too
so I'm just gonna for all of you now
I treat you all the same a cake box to
book said this is the bottom chosen nap
I am the game host what he calls the
game host he knows where the chocolates
ah knows where the prize is so now I'm
going to reveal something too okay I'm
going to reveal one of the boxes that
doesn't surprise me
ok ready so so so the box of people are
disappointed sorry but now now here's
where the game gets really interesting
ok you now face another choice they used
to magnet box to I've shown you box
three you have a choice now to stick
with box two or to sue
which two box one you've got a choice
now you want to stay with your original
option or do you want to switch now they
know that I've shown you this now before
I actually ask I'm going to get you to
vote in a second stick or switch and
this is all of you now regardless of
which box you chose okay I'm gonna ask
you stick with box to switch to box one
okay before I ask you I want you to
think about because this is a game of
chance isn't it right there are
probabilities involved so where is the
best chance he's there a best chance are
they all the same is one better than the
other
okay now I want you to think about that
I want you to vote now okay I want you
to raise your hands if you want to speak
with box two ends up okay okay so
sticking sticking with box to account
we've got one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve is it
the same for people
wait wait wait a second so that means
that tomorrow you want to go that way
zennith even split you want it what what
were you you were gonna you were gonna
switch so you'll you'll mastic okay okay
so are you ready for me to reveal where
the chocolates
congratulations okay so so so so there's
the prize now it is it is a game of
chance
isn't it okay really could have gone now
here's where it starts to get
interesting okay he's the paradox I'm
gonna know to you okay and it's I'm so
glad that we well we're just interested
in dinner away okay but in fact I gave
you a choice stick or switch sticker
switch okay now surely some people's
intuition says right well I had three
choices before one in three chance of
winning right now I have two choices so
there's a one in two chance of winning
right 15:52 outcomes seems logical
doesn't it
except it's not this was what she picked
originally right you actually despite
how the chances when you are actually
twice as likely to win if you switch
twice as likely now maybe you don't
believe me I'm going to prove